now fears are growing about the safety
and whereabouts of a chinese tennis star
who hasn't been heard from since she
accused a former chinese official of
sexual assault um tom standing by for us
in beijing what's happened to her tom
well no one knows we'll get into a bit
about what might have happened just um
to talk about this former chinese
official it's not just any official this
was uh john galli who's a vice premier
of china he was a member of the
politburo standing committee which is
the real upper echelons of chinese
society so when peng schwein wrote her
post saying she had been forced into sex
by mr zhang it completely resonated
around the chinese internet especially
with the me too movement which is often
suppressed by authorities that post was
taken down you still can't even send a
screenshot of that post using uh chinese
social media we've been trying that in
the bureau here it just doesn't go
through and we hadn't heard from her
despite calls from the tennis world from
players like naomi osaka novak djokovic
for more information as to her
whereabouts that changed around about
midnight beijing time when cgtn which is
the english language arm of cctv the
state broadcaster said it had seen an
email allegedly sent by pangshui to the
head of the women's tennis association
now this is what the email said it
started by saying hello everyone this is
pong shui and said the news in that
release including the allegation of
sexual assault is not true i'm not
missing nor am i unsafe i've just been
resting at home and everything is fine
thank you again for caring about me now
cgtn doesn't have a huge track record in
delivering big scoops like this it does
have a track record for airing forced
confessions it was actually fined by
ofcom the media regulator for doing just
that and this email hasn't convinced
many people including the head of the
wta simon stevens steve simon sorry he
said i have a hard time believing that
peng schwein actually wrote the email
we've received or believes what is being
attributed to her the wta and the rest
of the world need independent and
verifiable proof that she is safe steve
simon also added that he's been trying
to reach her himself through various
different means and hadn't had any reply
so as it stands we don't know where pong
shui is we certainly haven't seen video
of her or anything like that and it's
worth bearing in mind the context of
this not just the fact that the wta
plays lots of matches in china
it could potentially stop doing that
until they hear it but also here in
beijing they're getting ready to hold
the winter olympics in february at the
same time the chinese government has
apparently disappeared a three times
chinese olympian the hashtag online is
where is pungshui and i think the people
asking that question are only going to
ask it more loudly in the coming days